[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique à moins
de six mois des élections municipales
france 3 bourgogne donne la parole aux
maires des grandes villes de notre
région après celui du creusot et avant
ceux d'auxerre et de dijon c'est
aujourd'hui denis thuriau le maire de
nevers qui est l'invité de dimanche en
politique bilan de son mandat compte des
promesses tenues ou non il réagira aussi
à la vision que les noeuds vers soir ont
de leur ville
il nous dira enfin où ils se situent sur
l'échiquier politique dans un contexte
national très flou et vous qui nous
regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter en direct cette émission avec
le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne denis
thuriau bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation en direct ce
dimanche matin d'abord un mot sur
l'événement politique de la semaine les
obsèques lundi de l'ancien chef de
l'état jacques chirac et cette photo les
honneurs militaires rendus par emmanuel
macron à jacques chirac vous et lui en
termites et rendent yens successeur de
pierre bérégovoy
comment avez vous vécu cette disparition
va goûter la mise à l'honneur d'un chef
d'état qui a fait deux mandats
présidentiels dont qui a compté pour la
france était un homme proche des gens
après chacun ses obédiences politiques
mais encore une fois on peut tout à fait
respecté la fonction et et l'homme
donc j'ai considéré que le choix d'
emmanuel macron de rendre les honneurs
notamment militaire et était justifiée
alors juste la veille et une grande
partie de la nuit et une autre photo qui
est assez symbolique c'est cet afflux de
gens venus rendre hommage à jacques
chirac aux invalides les français qui
rendent hommage à leur ancien président
à l'ancien maire de paris c'est
finalement le rêve de tout politique de
son vivant d'être aimé par les gens
n'ont écouté même si je ne suis pas
forcément un défenseur de la politique
professionnelle il faut reconnaître que
jacques chirac occupé à peu près toutes
les fonctions je crois que ça a été le
seul premier ministre par deux fois dans
des gouvernements différents et donc il
avait une aura auprès des gens et il
avait une simplicité je crois près des
gens donc ils le lui ont vendus et c'est
tout à fait normal et voilà cette foule
démontre que est à présent la république
et un maire de paris je crois que les
deux fonctions finalement quelque part
sont très différentes mais ce sont
celles auxquelles les français sont le
plus attachés
l'ancien maire de paris peut être une
source d'inspiration pour le maire
à l'heure actuelle difficile de comparer
nos verres et peut-être la très grande
banlieue de paris moi ça ne me dérange
pas sur le plan économique c'est
difficile de comparer deux villes très
différentes mais en tout cas ce que je
constate pour évoluer parmi les maires
depuis plus de cinq ans maintenant c'est
quelle que soit la taille de la ville on
est souvent confronté aux mêmes
difficultés après à chacun sa proportion
alors toujours pour parler des maires il
y a une semaine l'agression du maire de
montbrison dans la loire
une femme de 34 ans a été condamné à
quatre mois de prison avec sursis ce
mercredi par le tribunal de grande
instance de saint-etienne pour avoir
craché et insulté christophe basile
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
on sait que vous même vous avez été
confronté à ce type d'agression à
plusieurs reprises les gens n'aiment
plus leur mère non je ne crois pas mais
je crois que ça participe à l'air du
temps malheureusement qui a peut-être
vouloir être excessivement réactionnaire
mais j'crois que l'éducation c'est pas
réactionnaires il ya un manque de
respect parfois vous pas généraliser il
ya aussi des des générations très bien
d'ailleurs
l'âge de la personne qu'on a des démonte
pas qu'on est forcément jeunes je crois
qu'il ya une difficulté aujourd'hui à au
respect j'ai effectivement été moi-même
violence de vie de pardon aux victimes
de violences physiques mon domicile est
aussi pris à partie la société agit
avant on aimait beaucoup son maire
qu'est ce qui se passe mais je crois que
la grande majorité des gens qui
continuaient mais leur mère est temps en
temps il ya des gens qui dérape et on
parle souvent des gens qui dérape et
souvent malheureusement pas assez de
ceux qui sont plutôt d'adéquation tout
cas dans le respect et je constate que
souvent les gens viennent me voir mais
ils ont coûté j'ai pas voté pour vous je
trouve ça d'ailleurs très sympathique
double derniers sont pas obligés mais je
reconnais que voilà ça permet un échange
donc c'est ça le respect des changes de
risques on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais en venir aux violences ou menaces
de mort comme parfois j'ai été aussi la
cible b c'est inadmissible avant d'être
acquitté républicaine non contraire ça
me renforce dans la volonté d'essayer de
contribuer à changer les choses on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de mères qui ne
veulent plus se représenter notamment
pour ces raisons 1
et puis la responsabilité qui repose sur
nos épaules qu'elle soit pénales ou
civiles
il faut une protection du maire qu'elle
soit automatique on n'a pas besoin de
voter au conseil municipal voilà fois
certain nombre de mesures le sénat s'est
emparé de ces difficultés vis-à-vis des
mères je pense que beaucoup de maires
quelle que soit leur tendance politique
maintenant ce que je peux constater la
plupart ils font de leur mieux et c'est
pas simple de faire de son mieux font
leur mieux de leur mieux au profit de
l'intérêt général ça faut le reconnaître
et concédé alors de nature you avant de
nous dire
ce que vous comptez faire et quel est
votre bilan vu par vous même le bilan de
leur mère par les noeuds vers soi j'aime
j'aime pas à nevers propos recueillis
par notre équipe sur place rémy chidaine
et tanya gomez
j'aime bien le verbe côté historique de
la ville bon c'est vrai que c'est une
ville qui a beaucoup perdu parce que
déjà il ya plus beaucoup de jeunes parce
qu'il ya plus de travail sur le verre le
calme et la ville centre et vous voyez
c'est pas mal là maintenant on est bien
ils ont fait des travaux et tous les ans
faisait bon se souvient y aurait
beaucoup d'entretien affaire c'est que
vous n'avez jamais passé là bas c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment des laptev
vraiment voilà c'est ce que je dis
son architecture son histoire ses
travaux ce qui est triste c'est qu'elle
n'a pas évolué pendant pendant
nombreuses années et c'est difficile de
la faire revivre actuellement c'est
dommage parce que c'était lui qui
meurent quoi avant j'habitais à nantes
j'ai habité aussi dans une grande ville
dans le sud et il y avait beaucoup de
bruit beaucoup de problèmes et tout ça
et depuis que je suis ici mais jamais
rien quoi donc ce faisant il n'y a pas
assez
deux magasins jeudi passé de d'endroits
on peut sortir aussi du coup on s'ennuie
beaucoup à la rue saint-martin été
refaite mon lieu de travail qui est
superbe la porte de paris le petit
théâtre on a un cadre de vie calme beau
disque au contraire il ya des choses que
vous aimez - des choses qui vous pose
plus problème qui pouvait être changée
alors je dirais la circulation générale
vient d'un peu plus de magasins de
proximité des magasins
voilà la maison de la culture l'acquis
et maghrébins qui effectivement il le
fallait quoi elle n'était pas très très
belle en train de le faire le la ville
est propre et oui mais il ya beaucoup de
magasins fermés ou si on va en venir
dans un instant bien sûr à la question
du commerce de centre-ville qu'une
question récurrente notamment à nevers
mais pas celles non mais mais la
première question c'est un peu comment
on fait pour continuer à garder une
attractivité dans une ville moyenne
comme nevers comment faire en sorte que
les jeunes et les familles s'y
installent comment faire en sorte qu'on
ne perde pas d'habitants denis curieux
moi je n'étais pas confrontés quand j'ai
été élu à comment garder de
l'attractivité parce qu'il n'est plus
beaucoup
j'étais confronté à comment recréer ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait pareil paris
ne s'est pas fait en un jour c'est plus
compliqué encore c'est ça c'est plus
compliqué en même temps peut partir à la
fois quelque part de fâches blanche et
se donner voilà de nouveaux angles
d'attaqué si je puis dire
mais voilà nevers est à moins de deux
heures de paris on sait qu'on a pâti du
non développement de l'a77 de l'absence
de tgv voulait faire venir pierre
bagouet tu sais tout ça ce sont des
grands projets qui n'auraient
désenclaver ce paradoxe d'être en centre
de france et peu de gens forcément
savent où nous sommes c'est ça qui est
un paradoxe est donc faut retrouver
l'image mais derrière l'image
il faut du fonds et le fond il faut
retravailler les filières classiques
l'automobile le charolais etc mais ça
n'a pas suffi effectivement nous avons
perdu 13 mille habitants 25 ans ce qui
est
rare à ce poids là ça a été le cas dans
beaucoup de villes mais diane bérard
pour une ville vraiment positionné
ensemble de la france donc l'enjeu
c'était aussi de partir sur l'innovation
les nouvelles technologies qui vont nous
aider aussi sur le développement durable
derrière d'avoir créé des choses
nouvelles qui font qu'aujourd'hui on ait
des familles qui s'installent à nos
verres il faut sortir au site ce
négativisme dans lequel on était trop
longtemps c'est des clichés il ya plus d
appuis assez de commerce oui toutes les
villes où on entend quand même si ses
habitants de votre vie marles
quand il ya eu on a croisé une jeune
alors qu'on a eu on a pas mal de
personnes âgées qui nous ont dit il ya
plus de jeunes à nevers donc il y en a
encore c'est ce moment on en a mais par
contre cette jeune fille elle dit mais
il n'y a pas grand chose pour les jeunes
mais c'est faux alors je les quitte à
passer une journée avec moi je fais des
journaux remettre ses ingénieurs mère si
elle nous regarde journée avec moi elle
va vivre ce que c'est qu'une journée
demain ou président d'agglo ou les deux
et puis je l mais c'est celle qui a dit
je crois je m'ennuie à moi je ne me suis
jamais ennuyé à nevers je sais pas
exactement le même âge n'a peut-être pas
ce sens vous faire offense à la
peut-être d'autres en vue d'autres
qu'elle aille sur le problème de la
culture d'haïti théâtre que nous avons
ouvert un nouvel programme est ce qu'on
la rue elle aussi qu'ils le calvez
charlesbourg du jazz qui va commencer
franchement tout l'été y des choses je
défie ceux qui s'ennuient de le faire
pour de vrai parce que s'ils veulent
sortir tous les soirs ils peuvent le
faire même anneau vert et oui mais alors
on a vu une photo d'art et vous il ya
deux petites secondes celle d'un
commerce fermé à nevers une des villes
où le taux de vacance commerciales les
plus importants de france comment est-ce
qu'on inverse la donne et l'initiative
nevers coeur de ville
notamment vous avez reçu la ministre
jacqueline gourault pour lancer cette
opération vous étiez même l'un des
pionniers en france en la matière est ce
que c'est suffisant et est-ce que ça
commence déjà à produire ses effets et
j'étais correct action logement
avant-hier qui va beaucoup investir sur
la rénovation des logements parce que on
a des gens qui reviennent vivent en
centre-ville mais faut aussi des
logements qui convienne qui soit digne
du 21e siècle et qu'il soit là il ya un
vrai dossier sur la ligne magique maire
de nevers vous avez beaucoup de
commerces comme partout d'ailleurs où le
commerçant habitait au dessus c'est fini
ce temps là par contre faut créer des
ouvertures différentes faut recréer des
logements et la ville va d'ailleurs
investir par son droit de préemption va
racheter quelques cellules pour
maîtriser le coût du loyer pour les
rénover pour proposer des cellules plus
grande des logements les deux ans le
baril comme énergie mais il ya des trop
petites cellules qui n'intéressent pas
certaines chaînes et donc si on réunit
des cellules parfois à côté on va
profiter que certains
soit vide côte à côte pour en faire
qu'une et donc c'est le rôle aussi d'une
ville après la remettre sur le marché
que les une dame qui dit il faudrait
plus de commerces de bouche est ce que
vous avez conscience d'un manque de
commerces de proximité en centre ville
alors ce que j'ai ce dont j'ai
conscience et quand tu arrives en 2014
24% de vacances commercial voilà
aujourd'hui ça a baissé ses fragiles
alors c'est quoi le je suis prudent on
doit être un tour dans 19%
non on doit être autour de 19 ans assez
compliqué parce que vous allez calcul à
ses idoles insee sait jamais exactement
le même périmètre fermé ça reste parmi
les plus importants de france où il
baisse
aujourd'hui j'ai plus de commerces qui
ouvrent que deux commerces qui ferment
centre ville voilà maintenant je suis
humble parce que c'est pas simple mais
la première des chevaux dans quelle
mesure ça dépend que la première des
choses c'est pas le maire c'est le
consommateur et moi je vois parfois des
gens qu'on interroge sur des parkings de
grandes surfaces très bien c'est de
l'emploi elles existent je vais pas les
démolir comme parfois ceux qui les
avaient autorisés voulait faire
aujourd'hui rouler bon courage et
démolir bien évidemment que non par
contre ce qu'il faut c'est que tout le
monde puis zions complémentarité et dans
mes rencontres très fréquentes avec les
neuf et reçoit notamment dans des petits
groupes où les gens peuvent s'exprimer
il est souvent ils me disaient mais bien
mais je lui dise que vous y alliez ah
bah oui c'était pratique quand j'ai
oublié 4,02 j allais
comment voulez vous qu'un commercial
donc il faut savoir ce que l'on veut on
veut du cycle mais pas de piscine là
parce que ça gêne on veut du commerce de
centre ville mais on va faire ses
courses ailleurs en périphérie voilà il
ya une contradiction chez les
consommateurs cependant c'est homer
d'impulser le changement d'impulser une
nouvelle vision de cette façon de
consommer alors vous avez fait quelque
chose vous avez par exemple instaurer le
stationnement gratuit en centre ville
dans les fameuses zones bleues est ce
que c'était vraiment la bonne solution à
l'heure où great attenberg mobilise les
jeunes pour le climat pour sauver la
planète
vous vous incitez les voitures à venir
jusqu'au centre ville on voit cette
photo de du parcmètre cacher parce qu'il
ne sert plus beaucoup il sur des montées
même mai
voilà c'est les grandes paroles les
grands principes très bien moi j'invite
greta tony berg à venir est maire de
nevers puis à lui gratte ça n'est pas si
simple
donc voilà je ne rejette pas tout ce
qu'elle dit c'est pas d'idée simplement
dans mes engagements dans nos
engagements de mon équipe il y avait la
relance du commerce est passé par de
nouveaux axes de circulation avant il y
avait 30 % de voix pénétrante et 70 ce
qui sortait on a rééquilibré
ça n'est pas leur chasse et la voiture
mais un jour il y aura plus besoin de la
voiture et la voiture autonome qui
arrive donc je suis en train de penser
aux nos verts de demain à la proche
périphérie les voitures iront se
stationner toute seule à revient sur
tout le monde n'aura pas de véhicule
autonome de suite mais ça pourrait être
pour tout pour les virtuoses amanda
c'est quoi c'est la piétonnisation
plutôt non alors moi je serais pour
développer un peu plus la piétonnisation
mais je travaille vraiment très en lien
avec les commerçants jeu pour pouvoir le
dire et pourront vous le confirmer à ce
qu'il y en a qui s'est impliqué très
favorable à l'organisation
j'aimerais que la voiture du client
arrive jusque devant leurs portes mais
ça faut changer nos habitudes et
pourquoi j'ai fait le stationnement
gratuit je dis pas que c'est valable
dans toutes les villes pour moi si ça ne
marche pas je perds 700000 euros par an
pour moi si ça marche d'un
investissement si des commerces me
disent je retrouve du chiffre d'affaires
je vois des gens que je ne voyais pas je
vois des jeunes qui n'avaient pas
forcément les moyens de payer le
stationnement
ça semble être le cas voilà il faut un
peu de recul pour tout cela vous
imaginez je vais pas perdre pour la
ville sept cent mille euros par an si on
me dit ça ne va pas mieux et tout se
casse la figure
par contre refaire par exemple
l'aménagement urbain je prends l'exemple
d'une de la rue saint martin qui était
une rue très commerçante qu'il n'était
plus du tout
6 une version était attentif ya quatre
nouveaux commerces si on a deux lions
l'attention de ceux d'ouvrir nous avions
dit si on leur offre
si vous n'aviez pas refait l'aménagement
urbain je serais allé en périphérie et
ses trousses resté désert d'eau à nous
d'impulser tu avais raison à nous
d'améliorer le cadre de vie et puis
quand les gens viennent consommer en
coeur de ville la plupart du temps c'est
pour se promener c'est pour être dans un
cadre agréable
attention dans un cycle qui se casse la
figure justement une photo c'est celle
du beffroi un symbole de nevers s'il en
est un symbole parfois d'un nevers en
mauvais état d'un nevers délabrée que
vous peinez à restaurer
parce que ça a un coût tout simplement
est ce que est ce que c'est difficile
d'entretenir tout ce patrimoine est ce
que c'est d'autant plus difficile quand
parallèlement ont fait le choix de
baisser la fiscalité ce que vous avez
essayé de faire trois ans malgré une
grosse baisse de dotation alex est
décidée par le précédent gouvernement
mais du coup se défroisse était symbole
pour moi de nos verres
se casse la figure par des mois de
familier et c'était pas prévu et c'est
le cas et c'est un million et demi et
c'est le million et demi que j'aurais pu
mettre dans la rénovation du stade de la
baratte qui accueille les championnats
de france d'athlétisme et qui ont qui le
mérite et que je ne pourrais pas faire
dans ce mandat là il faut que les neuf
et reçoit le sache
par contre se défera aujourd'hui c'est
un bâtiment qui est peu visible donc peu
à vertus électorale comme on le dit
souvent mais moi ça m'est égal je suis
lent responsabilité là la longueur de la
de la panne de ce beffroi à un briquet
dans les maisons est supérieure à celle
de la cathédrale de bourges vous
imaginez ce bâtiment la complexité qui
est oui je dis qu'avant on savait qu'il
fallait le refaire qu'on ne l'a pas fait
donc on nous a laissé ce cadeau
empoisonné ben on assume par contre
quand j'ai été élu j'ai reçu l'ancien
architecte des monuments historiques il
m'a donné la note 20 millions pour pas
que ça tombe l'hôtel de ville la porte
de paris oui c'est le beffroi et voilà
c'est un symbole d'une ville qui est
compliqué entre d'exactement donc on a
mis chaque année 3 4 5 millions par an
on a planifié et on y arrive et c'est
compliqué mais on a une aide
supplémentaire de la drac est bien
consciente des difficultés mot vert et
le deuxième patrimoine de bourgogne
après dijon ça a été rappelé par une
personne que j'avais interrogé dans la
rue c'est une de nos richesses mais un
patrimoine si tentant d'isoler est
compliqué c'est compliqué donc par
contre c'est une richesse touristique on
a beaucoup de touristes et en le
rénovant se remet à niveau mais il n'ya
pas que ce patron à raj et rénové oui il
ya le patrimoine naturel la loi
retourner la vie sur la loire c'était
complètement inexistant par avant le
patrimoine sportif le patrimoine
culturel le théâtre la maison de la
culture on en a parlé et café charbon
dans le même mandat on aura lancé 3 ou
réaliser 3 rénovation allons parler de
fiscalité vous avez fait le choix de
baisser la fiscalité à nevers c'était un
de vos engagements de campagne moins que
prévu finalement en raison des baisses
de dotations mais parce que quand on a
décidé ça dans la campagne en 2013 on ne
connaissait pas quelle sauce on sera
mangé par l'ancien gouvernement donc il
faut être raisonnable au bout d'un
moment c'est ce que voulait me dire
l'actuel et mieux gouvernement faux oui
vous savez pas vous dire le contraire
mais c'est la problématique avait
surtout pour nos verres faut s'adapter
c'est pas parce qu'on décide quel besoin
à l'instant t sue qui sait pas s'adapter
il va conduire la ville dans le mur donc
oui on a dû modifier cela étant dit au
niveau de la taxe d'habitation qui va
bientôt disparaître et beaucoup de nos
versoix vont être concernés d'ores et
déjà par cette disparition est bien
nous sommes en deçà de la du taux moyen
des villes de médiane voilà donc on a
déjà fait ce progrès là en taxes
foncières est encore un peu d'efforts à
faire vous aviez pris 85 engagements de
campagne lors de la dernière élection
vous en êtes vous aujourd'hui c'est pas
les sens une proposition mais presque
oui j'apprécie beaucoup vous le disiez
parce que j'ai pas fait de promesse que
jamais de promesses comme sont des
changements de nom mais il sait très
bien que ça va souvent dit et vos
promesses moi j'ai pas fait de promesse
ne verrait bien obligé de vous engager
dans les années seulement aux côtés des
avocats jus contractuels j'ai fait des
engagements dans les engagements ça
serait texte un contrat entre notre
équipe et les noeuds vers soi on est
entre autour de 95% de réaliser ou de
lancer plus des projets pouvaient pas
prévues telles que le défaut d'autre
chose évidemment j'ai envie de montrer
une autre photo celle d'un stéthoscope
qu'on va voir arriver pour lutter contre
le manque de médecins
il y a désormais une première année de
médecine à nevers alors deux questions
est-ce qu'elle va être pérennisée
et est ce que comme le souhaitent
certains étudiants et leurs familles on
peut voir arriver une deuxième une
troisième année de médecine à nevers où
est ce que vraiment c'est pas l'objectif
et c'est impensable
je vais être très clair là-dessus tout
comme l'hélicoptère sanitaires que nous
n'avions pas la ville la plus éloignée
de bourgogne du chu dijon n'avait pas
d'hélicoptère sanitaire et que vous avez
dépensé grâce à vos bons rapports avec
le gouvernement à agnès buzyn et aux
prisons de république et je les ai reçus
souvenez vous quand il était candidat à
l'hôpital où sont hospitalière dr guell
je vais expliquer problématique et je
lui ai dit je ne demande pas de
privilèges mais je demande à ce que la
nièvre on arrête de l'écarter on arrête
de la sous-estimer et donc oui j'ai sans
doute contribué parce que je suis pas
tout seul mais aussi les parlementaires
y en a d'autres qui se sont battus là
dessus alors mes produits
cette proximité permet effectivement qu
ont été enfin entendus sur les capteurs
sanitaires et nous recevons avec le prix
du département
le doyen de la faculté de médecine au
dijon le 23 octobre pour choisir le site
où seront dispensés des premiers cours
de cette première année mais mes
échanges avec nos miss de la santé me
laisse espérer que nous arriverons un
cycle de trois ans à terme
donc nous aurons enfin cette formation
médicale la réforme de la paces nous y
aide ça aussi la formation denis thuriau
parce que c'est une demande forte
notamment des étudiants qui se lancent
en médecine à l'envers mais j'en ai déjà
échangé que la mise de la santé après
tout ne dépend pas d'elle mais
je j'étais avec le directeur de cabinet
du présent et public il ya quinze jours
à l'elysée je lui ai reparlé de cet
enjeu est donc oui je vais tout faire
contribuer encore une fois je ne dis pas
juste moi qui fait tout mais quand on
s'y met tous c'est plus facile et sur la
santé on est tous d'accord
donc voilà j'espère qu'un jour on
proposera un cycle d'études de santé de
trois ans alors vous l'école
d'ergothérapie l'école de kinésithérapie
qui vaut 20 en 2020 et enfin une antenne
débuté en 2020 les moyens vont nous être
donnée à vous savez pendant la campagne
des élections municipales il ya le
fameux sentiment d'insécurité qui
revient alors je vous propose de parler
de sécurité notamment avec une photo de
caméras de vidéoprotection vous avez
développer la vidéoprotection en
centre-ville armée la police municipale
est ce que les quartiers en périphérie
ne doivent pas aussi bénéficier de ce
système de vidéoprotection mais ils ont
bénéficié
gmail et la ville malheureusement pas
autant que j'aurais voulu parce que ce
sont des budgets même si on est aidé par
l'état et je compte poursuivre et
aujourd'hui j'ai été moi-même longtemps
compte en tant qu'avocat je suis très
attaché aussi protection individuelle en
tant qu'élu aujourd'hui faut reconnaître
c'est une nécessité et certains
commerces notamment quartiers
prioritaires nous demandent des caméras
maintenant si on parle de sécurité je
rappelle que là où il ya le plus
d'infractions c'est pas dans les
quartiers soi-disant difficile ou
prioritaire c'est en centre ville si on
sent trop vite donc on a veillé
principal c'est solide vous avez
prioriser le centre on va dire les
sorties de ville parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est de suivre quelqu'un et
les résultats effectivement sont très
favorables sans doute à la fois un peu
dissuasion et surtout à réparer de
l'impunité si on laisse des gens impunis
c'est la récidive je le sais bien dans
quel de mon métier qui est encouragée
mais ces caméras
aujourd'hui j'en avais sur dans tous les
quartiers de la ville et j'y tenais et
vous allez ça va continuer à se
développer si nouveau dans le quartier
du banlay où il ya les 10 et qui est en
train d'être complètement rénové dans le
code de la rue alors denis curieux je
vous propose d'aller retrouver les
habitants de nevers on leur a demandé
s'ils avaient quelque chose à vous dire
des remarques ou des questions à vous
poser on les écoute
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent faire pour
essayer de garder un peu la jeunesse sur
nevers mais étant donné qu'il ya pas de
trop de travail a plus d'industrie a
plus rien donc je pense que c'est assez
difficile
davy plus vivante plus agréable
eux qui se sont - dr comme ça
actuellement quoi les est difficile le
projet de la place mohseni tient à coeur
parce qu'effectivement si ça se faisait
ça soit vraiment très bien parce que ce
serait un bel endroit et donc on compte
sur lui à caen on peut être le plus de
stationnement pour le centre-ville
commettre autant de pouvoir mieux
stationner perdent également leur attire
également un flux au niveau de votre vie
doit par rapport aux zones l'extérieur
la semaine au rize à sion mais je crois
que c'est en cours de préparation pour
sonoriser la ville donner un petit air
un petit peu plus joyeux redynamiser le
centre-ville faire que les gens y
viennent un peu plus sinon bah je te
mangerais fait ce qu'il peut est-ce
qu'il pense améliorer pour les sans
domicile fixe et hébergement parce que
c'est compliqué pour tout le monde et
pour les sans domicile fixe je mon fils
qui habite avenue de la gare la vie est
très compliquée à mener d'un gars le
soir lui dire qu'il continue dans la
voie là qu'il a entrepris si vous aviez
une question ou une remorque à faire au
maire de nevers qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez vivre qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez lui demande est
particulièrement com
un peu plus d'attractions dans la vigne
pour les jeunes et puis les enfants et
tous développé plus la ville en fête
quand est ce qu'il pourrait faire plus
de choses pour les jeunes aussi parce
que il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées
mais aussi beaucoup de jeunes de plus en
plus et ce serait bien de développer
plus voilà denis curieux on l'a entendu
les jeunes c'était au début la dame
commence par dire oui il faut attirer
des jeunes et puis à la fin
la jeune fille qu'il faut attirer les
jeunes alors comment on fait pour
attirer les jeunes ça passe évidemment
par la question de l'emploi
et ça c'est une problématique que vous
avez particulièrement à nevers mais
c'est évidemment pas la seule ville de
la région qui à cette problématique dans
ce que nous avons entendu nous avons
entendu à la fois il ya plus de jeunes
est à la fois de plus en plus de jeunes
oreilles c'est compliqué quand on est
maire évidemment c'est très très
difficile d'emmener tout le monde dans
la prise de conscience générale et puis
c'est un cercle vicieux aussi c'est à
dire que évidemment s'il n'y a pas de
jeu n'y a pas d'emploi cia n'a pas
d'emploi pas de jeunes ainsi que c'est
compliqué d'en sortir
on voit qu'ils ont encore du travail
pour changer notre image y compris
auprès de nos propres concitoyens c'est
à dire qu'en fait on est sur des
caricatures ou des vieux précepte et
c'est plus ça c'est faux nous avons des
jeunes la tranche 18-24 ans et + 9 % de
la population de nos verges parle de nos
verres intra muros la moyenne régionale
et nationale ça un peu plus de 6%
donc nous en avons il faut démultiplier
l'offre de formation que ce soit
supérieur on en a parlé le campus
connecter des 13 villes du campus
connectés 18 étudiants l'école
d'ergothérapie plus de 30 étudiants en
kinésithérapie 30 étudiants l'année
prochaine nous sommes partis en 2014 de
2400 étudiants aujourd'hui nous sommes à
presque 2008 miser sur le avec un
objectif de plus de 3000 ces jeunes-là
trouvent un emploi sur place et reste
vivre parce que y'a pas plus
d'industries comme l'a dit la dame et
j'invite des industriels on est aussi
territoire d'industrie que je co pilote
il ya plein d'entreprises industrielles
qui n'arrivent pas à embaucher
il faut aller aux portes ouvertes il
faut un nom d'allah être saisie des
mânes de la nacelle numérique à nevers
à travers notamment l'incubateur on voit
cependant que des entreprises qui n'ont
pas tenu le choc
est-ce qu'il faut continuer dans cette
voie malgré tout vous savez j'ai été
très surpris moi même depuis l'existence
de la cub l'incubateur numérique 4000
mètres carrés la banque de france dedans
mais si vous enlevez maintenant j'avais
le village by ca avec lequel je
travaille beaucoup luc meunier c'est
vrai que tout cela fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons presque 200 emplois dans les
clubs donc oui ça marche
il ya des gens qui viennent après vous
savez dans le monde des start up voilà
il y en a les start up qui mit à 30% qui
continue nous celle inverse
il y en a 80 % qu'au continuer c'était
assez exceptionnel mais si la vie
économique moi je ne sais pas moi qui
ouvre le rideau le matin qu'ils le
ferment le soir à l'entreprise d'évoluer
nous lui donne les conditions on va il
nous reste très peu de temps on va faire
des réponses courtes je vais vous
montrer une photo vous connaissez ce
personnage c'est celle d' emmanuel
macron alors on vous a longtemps dit ma
chronique avant l'heure vous l'homme de
gauche qui a su rassembler largement à
gauche et à droite pour conquérir la
mairie de nevers aujourd'hui vous avez
adhéré la république en marche
est-ce que c'est toujours aussi cohérent
on a eu des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux de d'habitants de nevers qui
disent on se sent trahie on avait élu un
maire sans étiquette on se retrouve avec
un maire la république en marche qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez mais trahie de
quoi d'abord moi je ne porte pas une
politique nationale à nos verres
j'essaye de me faire aider par la
politique nationale est manifestement il
ya des résultats n'en a parlé tout à
l'heure
par contre la vraie question que je me
suis posée c'est ce que la république en
marche aurait existe en 2013
ça ne m'aurait pas convenu parce que
j'avais quitté le parti socialiste je ne
me retrouvais plus dans les partis
traditionnels
et quand on voit les résultats aux
dernières élections c'est toujours le
cas que ce soit gauche a besoin de
reprendre une éthique j'avais pas besoin
c'est à dire que ce que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs même le privé république
mélodies c'était précurseur et l'huile a
porté sur un plan national il ya aucune
incohérence là-dedans finalement moi je
me retrouve à titre individuel dans ce
qui est porté par contre mon équipe va
continuer de rassembler des gens en
marche ou pas en marche et j'ai envie de
vous dire l'importance et quoique je
suis en marge soit un ex ps on s'en
fiche de ça l'important
le père marie c'est que je gère phare
maman mais écoutez je vous invite les
électeurs à répondre à la question
suivante est ce que j'ai fait le job en
tant que maire ou pas quand on rassemble
comme ça à droite à gauche comme l'a
fait manuel macro comme vous l'avez fait
à nevers on tue un peu son opposition
du coup est ce que ça ne
ne tue pas aussi un peu le débat
démocratique quand peut-être demain vous
aurez comme seul adversaire identifiée
ou identifiable le rassemblement
national
je ne sais pas s'il va simplement
nationale viendra parce que le
rassemblement national veut aller là où
il gagnera et nos verts n'est pas prêt
au front national et j'y veille et
heureusement notre front national n'est
pas pro front national puis si on a une
à son jeu à la sonatt ray et j'ai la
prétention de dire que le mouvement
alternatif que nous avons menées à
baisser le front national parce qu'il ya
des gens qui ne savaient pas quoi voter
ça fait baisser la droite et la gauche
aussi
mais ça fait baisser front national moi
c'est mon objectif et je veux jouer
c'est pour maintenant du front national
sage en temps mais je vous parle de ce
débat démocratique qui du coup n'existe
plus vraiment on n'arrive pas à
identifier d'ailleurs vos opposants pour
les prochaines élections municipales
c'est très compliqué les derniers
conseils municipaux nous avons réussi à
voter un certain nombre de mesures à
l'unanimité absolue
donc je me réjouis parce que ça veut
dire quelque part qu'une politique
locale on peut tout à fait se mettre
d'accord au delà des appartenances où
nos politiques
et je rappelle qu'en marche comme moi
c'est la société civile avant tout c'est
les neuf et reçoit qui sont venus
marquer son intention quand on tue ses
opposants politiquement j'entends et les
oppositions viennent du propre camp de
la majorité
est ce que vous regrettez qu'ils aient
eu des dissensions des gens qui ont
quitté votre majorité nous je le savais
d'avancé il fallait pas aimé jean
baptiste mais mais mais mais vous savez
dans tout groupe
vous l'aviez d'alliances mais je me
doute aidé à vous les connaissiez la vie
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille pas
forcément mais je savais d'avancé parce
que en fait ce sont partis c'est 20 % et
ceux qui sont restés c'est 80% alors ça
c'est vous vouliez qui fait les cons que
je vous fais confiance là dessus on va
regarder parce qu'on vous a demandé un
selphy dans un lieu de votre choix
à nevers et vous avez choisi la porte de
paris rénové alors il nous reste moins
d'une minute dites-nous part ça serait
prétentieux sujet que c'était le
triomphe de nos verts mais c'est notre
as de triomphe pour moi c'est le symbole
surtout voilà d'une rénovation entamés
de la ville c'est compliqué il faut du
temps faut surtout réunir des budgets
mais voilà j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
toute la politique de rénovation qui est
visible mais pour moi c'est un symbole
et beaucoup de nos versions se prennent
encore en selle filles même même si
juste merci voilà merci denis thuriau
d'avoir accepté le principe de cette
émission la semaine prochaine à votre
place le maire d'auxerre guy férez
merci de nous avoir suivis aujourd'hui
un instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale suivi de la partie nationale
de dimanche en politique francis
letellier reçoit jean baptiste djebbari
le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports
bon dimanche à tous